una gran valla con carteles a favor de
la fórmula demócrata bein en harry los
demócratas de texas sienten que pueden
convertir el estado tradicionalmente
republicano en azul en los próximos
comicios
la organización proinmigrante scioli
action está los electores latinos a
registrarse y ejercer el voto
especialmente entre los más jóvenes
esta caso es tan importante para mí
porque como no solamente una casa que
afecta a mi yo porque yo obviamente yo
puedo votar yo puedo usar mi voz para
elegir o escoger quien quiero que me
representa en el estado de texas aquí en
la ciudad de houston en el federal y en
el sistema federal pero yo cuando quiero
usar mi voz yo no estoy solo pensando en
mí estoy pensando en mi familia mi
comunidad
si bien el electorado tejano está
cambiando texas continúa siendo el
bastión republicano de donald trump la
campaña por el presidente se hace desde
las iglesias con gran afluencia latina y
desde las calles como esta pareja de
pensionados que abogan por trump entre
sus vecinos apelando por el voto
conservador cristiano ha pensado en
muchas cosas
quizás se ha convertido
en sus valores más para alinear con
nosotros cristianos yo creo que se ha
alineado más en ser más pensativo en
texas el 34% de la población de votantes
elegibles son hispanos forman el
electorado con mayor crecimiento en el
estado y en 2022 será el primer estado
en el que los blancos serían una minoría
con muchos jóvenes migrantes de primera
generación habilitados a votar podría
significar un impulso al azul demócrata
tarde o temprano